[Musica]
chi di voi è insegnante
chi di voi è genitore chi di voi invece
si sente educatore o mentore e proprio
vero
tutti siamo educatori tutti siamo
mentori tutti abbiamo delle
responsabilità nei confronti degli
studenti nei confronti dei figli nei
confronti dei collaboratori che sfida la
sfida è proprio quella di educare da
educere tirar fuori il meglio dalle
persone che non qualche modo la vita ci
ha affidato e io nella mia attività di
educatore
ho sempre cercato di portare le persone
a quello che sarebbero potute essere
partendo dalle situazioni di competenze
e attitudini iniziali mi ha sempre
guidato questa frase di goethe trattati
un essere umano per quello che è e
rimarrà quello che trattate un essere
umano per quello che può e deve essere e
diventerà quello che può e deve essere e
trattare una persona per quello che può
e deve diventare è molto importante
perché in un mercato del lavoro che è in
rapida evoluzione noi dobbiamo garantire
che possano prosperare
perché questi scenari da gigi economy di
cui si è detto molto bene in precedenza
ci fanno dire che coloro che nascono
oggi molto probabilmente faranno un
lavoro che oggi non è stato ancora
inventato
e allora come facciamo noi a creare il
giusto mine set
io cercherò di rispondere a questa
domanda è innato oppure non si può
imparare ma prima ancora diamo una
risposta a queste domande quali sono le
abilità essenziali che all'interno di
un'organizzazione sono richieste
ringrazio seth godin perché
lea suddivise in abilità professionali e
abilità personali le abilità
professionali sono facili da
identificare come in questo caso questo
sito creato da robbie leonardi mostra
chiaramente che robbie leonardi è capace
di programmare perché presenta il
proprio curriculum vitae come se fosse
un videogioco
quindi i selezionatori in fase di
selezione hanno facilità ad identificare
le capacità di questa persona
inoltre le abilità professionali sono
anche facili da misurare
coloro che in questa sala hanno la mia
età sono della mia generazione
sicuramente si ricordano delle
dattilografe che venivano misurati sulla
base delle battute al minuto così come
non so se vi ricordate quei loschi
figuri che giravano all'interno dei
reparti chiamate funzione tempi e metodi
e che con il cronometro in mano
misuravano la produttività delle persone
invece le abilità personali sono un po
più di difficile misurazione pensate per
esempio alla difficoltà nel misurare le
responsabilità nel mezz'ora nel misurare
la capacità di assumersi rischi di
lavorare in team
eppure all'interno di un'organizzazione
se una persona pur avendo delle buone
capacità professionali viene colto nel
mentre ruba dalla cassa viene
immediatamente allontanato mentre una
persona invece che è disfattista che
rema contro l'organizzazione
ecco questa persona è più difficile
allontanamento e allora pensiamo un
attimo e viviamo queste nuove attività
regine
fai un interesse del conca clay del
piccolo ne va in tasse a del tipo che
nel 7 cambia
[Musica]
i gatti
i suoi cari
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ogni riferimento all'attualità è
puramente casuale ovviamente il gai la
king ha ottenuto il lavoro perché ha
dimostrato delle abilità personali e
selezionatori stanno cambiando il loro
approccio nei confronti di questa
tipologia di selezione ora cerchiamo di
capire ulteriormente come le abilità
professionali possano essere imparate
possono essere insegnate è facile
rispondere perché nessuno nasce con
delle competenze di costruire ponti
oppure delle competenze per tenere la
contabilità però le abilità personali
invece possono essere insegnate oppure è
imposti sono impossibili da insegnare
sgombriamo subito il campo queste soft
skill che col cosiddette abilità leggere
cosiddette abilità personali
in realtà sono abilitate sono abilità
reali sono abilità vive sono abilità
presenti tutti i giorni concrete che
solo persone che sono maestri veri
maestri competenti possono insegnare
maestri profondi possono insegnare
possono insegnare queste abilità reali
cioè la capacità di essere recettivi ai
trasferimenti delle competenze che la
l'organizzazione decide di trasferire in
modo carismatico li trasferiscono poi
altri collaboratori perché sono
orientati ai risultati e sanno motivare
oltre che essere motivati a loro volta
in modo paziente è capace di ascoltare
una delle modalità attraverso le quali è
possibile insegnare le abilità reali e
proprio l'introduzione
dell'imprenditorialità nella scuola se
questo ragazzo
fosse stato in una scuola che avesse
inserito nella propria attività
l'imprenditorialità sicuramente non
avrebbe avuto tarpate le ali della sua
intraprendenza e non avrebbe nemmeno
preso questa multa nella mia esperienza
il 20 per cento dei miei studenti
esercita un'attività imprenditoriale in
proprio contro una media nazionale che
ritorno al 23 per cento creando valore
per la comunità creando 8 c'è avendo
creato 800 posti di lavoro perché perché
si instillano nelle ragazzine gli
studenti
queste qualità queste abilità tipiche
dell'imprenditore di poter individuare i
bisogni di poter rispondere a questi
bisogni creando prodotti e servizi di
saper lavorare in team di saper avere
questo approccio questa mentalità da
imprenditore per individuare punti di
forza e punti di debolezza e i punti di
debolezza comportano poi come fa
tipicamente l'imprenditore la capacità
di trovare le conoscenze per prendere le
decisioni
ma abilità professionali e abilità reali
non bastano per generare talenti bisogna
ulteriormente
io dico stimare il lavoro proprio in
primo in primo luogo è il lavoro degli
altri
pensate che bello se all'interno della
scuola
i tre stakeholder principali studenti
genitori e docenti collaborassero fra di
loro e si stimasse la vicenda
pensate con quale gratitudine gli
studenti guarderebbero i docenti se
respirassero in casa la fiducia nel
lavoro che viene sviluppato dai docenti
e poi cambiamo la cultura del fallimento
dell'errore dello sbaglio
come se fosse negativo dobbiamo vederli
in modo positivo dobbiamo cambiare
questa mentalità perché perché l'errore
il fallimento lo sbaglio sono punti dire
partenza e forti dell'esperienza di
quello che è successo precedentemente
tant'è vero che nel mondo anglosassone
in particolare in quello americano
vengono inseriti nei cibi nel curriculum
vitae e le persone vengono valutate
positivamente dei selezionatori
infine tutto quello che abbiamo detto
prima sbaglio fallimento errore non
definisca mai la persona e questo ce lo
insegna gesù cristo in questo tra
l'altro ben riportato in questo
capolavoro del caravaggio la vocazione
di san matteo dove indica samp indica
matteo e lo chiama sé indipendentemente
dal mercato dal dal peccato che ha
commesso
e noi dobbiamo fare la stessa cosa nei
confronti di tutti coloro che la vita ci
ha affidato
noi non dobbiamo giudicarli per l'errore
per lo sbaglio per il fallimento ma
dobbiamo attrarli a noi
infine consentitemi di dire che i staj
chiù è in tempo di far desiderare le
persone di far sentire la nostalgia la
mancanza dello spazio siderale la
mancanza delle stelle perché solo in
questo modo noi possiamo creare persone
vere possiamo valorizzare la persona
tutti o almeno quasi tutti ci siamo
definiti all'inizio educatori allora
concludo dicendo
qualsiasi sia la questione qualsiasi sia
il problema
l'educazione è la soluzione grazie
[Applauso]